it's almost impossible to make your
first million dollars it you work your
ass off it's it's so hard and what it
really takes to do is to have the
discipline of not buying you don't
need to make that first meal is you got
to invest it Market's going to make you
eight percent and then I thought well my
sites are on five it's going to be
impossible it wasn't as hard to get to
five as it was to one then 50 was my
next goal I said if I get to five why
can't I get to 50. this may sound insane
but to get to 50 you just have to love
what you're doing once you're an
entrepreneur and you're building a
business and you're at it every day I
woke up one day I went there it is
and then the hunski is your next one you
know it's sort of like Savage and then
there comes a point where well I don't
need any more money this is good I need
more time because the whole deal the
reason you work your ass off is to be
free that's the whole point